j'avais annoncé un désastre on a annoncé
10 15 députés bon aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il y aura plusieurs dizaines de
députés heller à l'assemblée nationale
mais tout ça bien sûr c'est ce qui nous
écoutent pas ces histoires de boutique
c'est pas ça l'aurait été c'est qu'il
faut penser qu'un qui sera utile et
j'observe moins une chose c'est que les
députés on sait que les députés la
france insoumise seront systématiquement
compté député du rassemblement national
sont systématiquement contre les députés
de la majorité présidentielle seront
systématiquement peau et nous sans doute
on sera plus utile parce que on n'est
pas corsetée on sera libre et on votera
en fonction de l'intérêt général n'est
malheureusement